as we get into some mpm
qb on this 15th monday of the regular
season
mike zimmer a couple of times yesterday
went for it deep in his own end one was
kind of a barry switzer thing second
quarter five minutes 52 seconds left
fourth and one on their own 34 trailing
17-7
dalvin cook stopped for no gain the
bears kick a field goal it's 20-7 at
that point that one was odd to me it was
just odd that's the only word that i can
think of that doesn't involve profanity
it was odd to to go for it in that spot
and to do something as basic as run it
right into the teeth of the chicago
defense
the only thing i'd say is at least he
gave it to dalvin cook i mean the last
time he did something like that it was
down on the goal line but he gave it to
alexander madison and that didn't work
out so well and i said well if you had
dalvin cook it's a different situation
he had dalvin cook but i i do think this
was a different situation mike and how
deep they were and how early it was in
the game i just don't think you
go for it at that point and i know what
all the analytics people say oh you
still should have gone for it blah blah
i i agree with some of the analytics
stuff i just don't know if that early in
the game in that situation with the
score of the game that you go for
there's just too much time left and you
have a chance to come back you look at
what the bucks did and i realized the
vikings weren't playing the falcons and
we know how the falcons tend to fold
but they had plenty of time to mount a
comeback after that if they had just
punted the ball
look
i'll say what i said earlier today on
pft live about analytics and i think
there is definitely a place for
analytics it's important to understand
at a deep level the statistics generated
and the extent to which those statistics
will indeed predict future results but
those percentages that we see of going
forward versus punting and what you
should do and when you should do it
those are the result
of years and years of iterations to get
to those percentages
most football coaches do not have the
luxury of playing that out over the
course of years and years and years
they have limited opportunities and when
you start doing unconventional things
you end up getting fired before the
percentages start working in your favor
that is the big flaw with analytics you
don't have ten thousand chances to do
this same thing and hey if we do it ten
thousand times five thousand
and fifty of them are going to go this
way so we should always do it that way
no
and fourth on one
on your own 34 with or without dalvin
cook you don't run it into the teeth of
that defense you just don't do it and
not that at the end of the day it made a
huge difference to the game but it was
an attitude type of thing and here's
where i think it affected the vikings
shireen
when they needed it with two minutes
left fourth and one on their own 29
they threw
and it was the play that we've seen many
times over the last three years kirk
cousins time with the vikings he tries
to roll out and someone springs free and
is in his face and he's not fast enough
or mobile enough or elusive enough to
run away from that pressure so he had
that guy in his face who just kept
chasing him chasing him chasing him and
he eventually threw a bad pass and that
was that game over
yeah and they had gotten the
interception in the end zone before that
mike cameron dancer got that the bears
were driving they were at the six yard
line and they get the interception just
what they need they have plenty of time
to drive down and try to win the game
and and they couldn't do it and and that
fourth down play i think was emblematic
of of what this team has been this year
they haven't been able to make the plays
when they've had chances to make them
mike zimmer has proved to be very
aggressive this year i think more than
any other year and he's gone forward on
multiple occasions that you probably
question a little bit and on that first
one mike you know with with the
struggles that dan bailey has had i
would not have minded if you're
bypassing the field goal
to to try to go for it but that deep in
the end zone
in the end of your field i just don't
think you do it at that point when
you're still in the game and this is why
the vikings are where they are and why
they're going to be on the outside
looking in and why mike zimmer's going
to go into next season on the hot seat
perhaps the hottest seat of anybody in
the nfl mike
it is another example of how
an isolated handful of decisions
moments
calls whatever
determine the difference between making
it to the playoffs and not making it to
the playoffs and that if that handful of
moments over the course of 17 weeks go
your way if enough of them go your way
you're in if enough of them don't go
your way you're out we talked earlier
today on pft live about this whole colts
and texans dynamic two games two weeks
apart where the colts get some fluky
thing that goes their way to preserve a
victory you take away those two wins
cults are done
right they're done just those moments
cults are done those two things go their
way you take away one of them and they
may be done with when you look at the
fact that between the browns
and
the the colts or the titans and uh who
else is in that scrum that's trying to
to get a playoff berth the dolphins
somebody's going to not make it
and and it would bend the ravens it
would be the cults on the outside
looking in if those games hadn't gone
their way against the text and so it's
just crazy how it can happen but but uh
that just that's just what makes those
decisions even more important and it
puts so much weight on them and again
they're isolated decisions the idea
that you
you blindly adhere
to numbers that are the product of
thousands of opportunities to craft
those averages
how many of those decisions are made
with the season riding on it right so
yesterday's decisions by mike zimmer
were and they did not work out and i
really do think that the failure to gain
fourth and one early
influenced the decision to call what was
a badly failed pass play
late the giants went for it twice inside
field goal range once was a jim zorn
style fake field goal that was
as ugly as anything ever concocted by
the mind of jim zorn all due respect to
jim zorn and the other one was uh when
the giants were trailing simply seven to
three fourth and two on the sixth they
went for it gained a yard cleveland
scored a touchdown in the ensuing drive
to go up 13 to three let's hear from joe
judge on his decisions to go for it in
those two situations
field goals weren't going to win this
game so look i'm not afraid to call
things aggressively i'm not afraid if i
think we have a good scheme in a kicking
game to call a fake i'm not afraid to
run the ball fourth and one and we'll
play to our defense at times if we don't
get that we've got to go out there and
stand up defense our defense done that
consistently throughout the year we're
going to play the strengths of our team
but look i'm not afraid to call it
aggressively we went to this game with
that mindset so we've got to do a better
job making sure we coach it the right
way execute it the right way and come
out with the results we want
yeah look i
point i made earlier today if i can
recall it correctly and not butcher it
which is about a 50 50 proposition at
this point in the afternoon
i think that
you take the points against the browns
against the chiefs you go for the
touchdown against the browns you kick
field goals you put pressure on them and
their young quarterback and their
offense to answer you you have a better
chance of winning the game to take the
points you don't have that compulsion to
get a touchdown with
a team like the chiefs you get your
touchdowns when you can because they're
getting there so that's my high level
analytics not based analysis of the
situation you have to take into account
who the opponent is and what kind of
point scoring you're going to need to
win the game that's one of the reasons
why because look i've got an engineering
background i've taken high level math i
i respect math and it has a place
but there are some simplicities of
football that we are losing sight of and
one of the simplicities in this case is
what is the quality of the offense
you're facing
this offense isn't a high octane attack
that is destined to score 30 plus points
therefore you take your points when you
can it's that simple shireen
yeah mike to your point
if you're playing the chiefs you also
take into account the point of the game
okay we go back to that denver kansas
city game and we criticized vic fangio
for taking the punt instead of going for
it it was late in the game they were
giving the ball back to patrick mahomes
and the chiefs offense that was a bad
decision at that point you do go for it
but in this situation on the opening
drive to me you take those points you
get on the board hey we went right down
we drove it down their throats on the
first drive we're going to come back
we're going to do this all night we just
did it on the first possession we got on
the scoreboard that was just so
deflating when they took the kick off
and drove all the way down there and
came away with nothing the browns won
that the browns at that point had all
the momentum and you're one drive into
the game you had to get on the school
board at that point and you didn't do it
and i just thought that was huge i i
just thought it was a failure on joe
judge's part to get on the scoreboard
and and just say to the point of we're
going to do this all night we're going
to keep scoring all night we just moved
it down the field you don't know how
many points you're going to get your
defense is really good you have to think
as he said that you're going to be able
to stop the browns at some point and
maybe th the game would have gone
differently if they had gotten those
points early mike
it's an opportunity to knock a better
team a little bit wobbly early in the
game and that's one of the setups to
knocking them out if that's what you're
going to do that does not require
high-level analytics that is just gut
instinct and that is the way football
works for anyone who's paid attention to
it for a long time as you and i both
have
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports